When a massive star dies
it can erupt in a supernova.
For a split second it outshines
an entire galaxy.
But exactly what causes them has been
a mystery for more than 50 years.
Scientists can't just look inside the star
so the only way to figure out
what drives the explosion,
known as a 'core collapse supernova',
is to simulate it:
blowing up stars, virtually,
inside a computer.
The physics involved in supernova
explosions is complex.
And only with modern super computers
have physicists been able to model the process
in enough detail to get
stars to explode in 3D.
A blast which in reality takes
less than half a second
can take a supercomputer
six months to simulate.
But recent models suggest that
scientists are finally getting close
to understanding just what it is
that makes a supernova explode.
The simulations start
at the end of a star's life.
Having run low on hydrogen
the star starts to contract.
An iron core forms at its centre.
Matter from the core then
collapses under gravity
to form a neutron star at its heart:
a ball the size of a city, but which
packs in more matter than the Sun.
This is the star's core.
Thousands of times
smaller than the star itself,
but still a few hundred
kilometres across.
Physicists think the collapsing matter
hits the neutron star at the centre
sending a massive shockwave
rebounding outwards.
You can see the shockwave
here in light blue.
But then the wave meets
more falling matter;
it stalls and can't escape the core.
The star doesn't explode.
And that is where
simulations used to end.
But today's simulations go much further.
Tiny irregularities in the flow of matter
can quickly amplify
into massive oscillations.
These appear as a violent, liquid- like
sloshing of matter around the neutron star.
Meanwhile neutrinos, particles
produced within the neutron star,
ferociously heat up the surrounding matter
causing it to churn and bubble,
like water on a stove.
Eventually the intense heat of neutrinos
combines with the pressure
of these violent motions
and drives out the shock wave.
The wave accelerates out the core
and explodes into the star.
Though all this takes less
than half a second
the wave may take as long as
a day to reach the star's surface
and create the spectacular
fireworks we see.
Understanding this mechanism
will help astronomers
to unpick other important
processes in the cosmos,
such as how these violent explosions
create new atomic elements,
which are vital for seeding
fresh stars and planets.
Though physicists can't yet
claim to have a complete picture
their simulations are now good enough to
compare with real-life observations.
And if a supernova went off today, modern
detectors could measure more than ever before.
Detecting things like neutrinos
or gravitational waves,
which both sail through matter unimpeded,
would allow astronomers to see inside
the exploding star for the very first time.
But to make sense of any of those data,
astronomers need simulations - and lots of them.
Scientists think that the last supernova that
blew up in our galaxy was in around 1870
but they tend to go off about twice a century.
That means modellers need to
get their skates on.